this week on forward we speak with rob
henderson about luxury beliefs young men
and the ins and outs of human nature
this week on forward
[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to ford my
name is jules turpak and i'll be hosting
today i've been on about four or five
episodes so far but if you haven't tuned
into those i'll give a recap of who i am
one last time i'm a tekken digital
culture commentator predominantly on
tick tock and i find things like ubi and
independent politics to be essential
conversations for our future
i'm super excited about today's guest
today's guest is one of my favorite
twitter followers and his bio is
straight to the point interested in
human nature so we're gonna explore many
facets of that today rob henderson is a
phd student and gates cambridge scholar
at the university of cambridge he
received a bachelor's of science degree
in psychology from yale university and
is a veteran of the us air force
his writing has appeared in the new york
times the wall street journal and
colette among many other outlets
rob's main area of research is in moral
psychology and you may have even seen
him on the jordan peterson podcast
thanks for being here rob thanks jules
great to be here
so that's a super impressive bio but
what i find even more impressive and
surprising is your background and your
journey up until this point
it's definitely not that of a typical
yale college students and i would love
for people to hear it through your words
yeah sure so so like you mentioned i'm a
phd student here in cambridge in my uh
fourth and final year and before this i
studied psychology at yale's an
undergrad and worked as a research
assistant in a psych lab
there at the university but
before i entered these
universities my life was a lot different
so backing way up i
was born in los angeles
and
you know born into poverty i never knew
who my father was
my mother
became addicted to drugs
and
she
wasn't able to care for me
and so she
yeah i mean i was basically taken from
her and put into the foster care system
in los angeles and grew up in homes
around the city uh you know throughout
the 90s
and was later adopted
by this family this kind of working
class family into this dusty blue-collar
town in northern california called red
bluff
very poor town
at that time in the late 90s it was the
median household income was 27 000 a
year
uh you know just kind of run down very
high crime a lot of poverty
and that was where i spent the sort of
second half of my childhood after the
homes in l.a
um
even then you know after this adoption
there was still a lot of drama and
disorder my adoptive parents divorced my
adoptive father stopped speaking to me
after this divorce because he was angry
with my
mother for leaving him and so for me
after living in all those homes never
knowing my father and then my adoptive
father
uh severing ties with me it was really
hard for me as a little kid emotionally
and so
that was a main reason why my grades and
my performance in school suffered i
barely graduated high school i got
a 2.2 gpa when i graduated
um
and there were periods where i was in
danger of filling out
and so yeah right after high school when
i was 17 i enlisted uh joined the air
force and from there
kind of you know managed to redirect my
life after some false starts
and
you know ended up going to yale on the
gi bill so that was like the very uh
very short version sort of abbreviated
version of um you know sort of where i
wasn't and then how i got here
and what do you think were the pivotal
points in making and having you make
those changes was there a certain role
model that you had that really changed
things for you or like what different
aspects of your life made that pivot i
mean there were a few different things
it's always hard to isolate um the sort
of specific key factors but
i'm i'm writing a memoir right now and
of course like as i'm working on it i am
i am sort of forced to identify those
key moments and and there are a couple
of ideas that that come to mind one was
you know i i did have this this period
of stability in my uh adolescence so
my adoptive mother after her divorce for
my adoptive father she entered a
relationship with a woman and together
her partner raised me for a few years
from when i was about nine nine to
fourteen so right before i started high
school and i recall this period uh as
being relatively stable i was still
getting into trouble still getting into
fights and and you know doing drugs and
still doing a lot of
reckless things
but it didn't get too out of hand in
part i think because i did have this
solid home base and these caretakers
that i could rely on
and who were there for me
um
and part of the reason why i enlisted uh
there were a couple of different
experiences i had one i had a male
history teacher who himself was a
veteran of the air force and he sort of
encouraged me to enlist he
you know i think he spotted some
potential in me that i was maybe
unwilling to see for myself he saw that
i was kind of a curious kid who
was just kind of admired in
uh chaos at home and
was you know spending a lot of time with
friends who maybe didn't have my best
interest in mind
so he thought maybe if i enlisted that
that would sort of pull me out of that
and so those are just a couple of the i
think uh sort of what um
protective factors in in my early life
that that helped me and in comparison to
how you grew up what was the culture
shock of yale like when you landed there
it was unbelievable i mean
i of course like you know these elite
schools have a reputation for being you
know full you know rich themselves full
of rich students and
you know that kind of thing you know
they're in the movies and whatever so i
had like that i guess sort of stereotype
but um you know that didn't really
prepare me for what what i experienced
my you know so let's see i i was
honorably discharged from the military
in uh august started class in september
like literally a week later you know i i
was stationed in germany so i like moved
from germany to new haven to start
classes
i had been a poor student in high school
so it was a little bit difficult to sort
of uh transition into taking academics
so seriously especially in this sort of
high stress competitive atmosphere at a
school like that um
but you know i managed and then um
you know i i remember my my first
semester there a few weeks in i tried to
get into this class called uh the
concept of the problem child taught by a
renowned child uh development expert
and i was interested in this class for
obvious reasons yeah given my own
history
and
i didn't get in which made sense to me
and i was first year student and this
class was mainly geared towards fourth
year students who maybe had a little bit
more experience and sort of more of a
background i guess in psychology
um
i emailed the professor and asked you
know or i said you know thank you for
offering this course and asked some
questions about it she encouraged me to
apply
the next time she offered it um and i
was very encouraged by this because i
didn't even expect to write me back but
i never got to take this course because
the course was taught by erica
christakis
and a lot of people will know that erica
christakis
resigned from her teaching position at
yale because there was a student
uprising at the university
demanding for her and her husband to be
fired
because she essentially defended freedom
of expression in an email um
in response to the administration
and sort of stood up for you know
whatever the right to sort of express
yourself and to not get
um diversity admission and bureaucracy
involved in students lives
and the stu many students not all of
them but many uh interpreted remarks as
you know at least they claim to have
interpreted them as a defending inter uh
what cultural appropriation and uh sort
of uh defending bigotry and prejudice
and all of this stuff and what are these
terms
yeah well that was one thing was uh i
had no idea what cultural appropriation
was
uh and so you know a lot of yeah so i
read that email a few times didn't get
it and
understand this i mean it was it was you
know i think a lot of people sort of
don't understand just how big this was
at that university it was covered in the
national news and everything in the
media but experiencing it firsthand it
was it was all encompassing it was
everywhere um it sort of took over all
of the conversations of the university
for for a few weeks
um and so that was a massive culture
shock for me
to see um
you know i had thought of this place as
this you know university that attracted
thoughtful
interesting people who were willing to
discuss ideas and uh and instead i i saw
them you know asking professors to be
fired for defending that idea so that
was really um you know very much at odds
with with my uh belief about what a
university was um so so yeah that was my
sort of introduction to uh higher
education in america
[Music]
something i found super interesting
about one of your new york times opinion
pieces called everything i know about
elite america i learned from fresh
prince and west wing i thought that was
fascinating in the way that it was kind
of like these different levels each show
that you watched you realized okay this
this is seems like a social class or
above me and then like you moved on to
another show and you're like okay this
is even above that like social class and
it's kind of like you learned through
that but there's nothing like
experiencing experiencing it in real
time i really enjoyed working on that um
it was basically my a discussion of my
experience with television and pop
culture and how that sort of informed my
views about class in america
and so i wrote in that piece you know
initially i thought that class was
mostly uh centered on money
and in part that was because
that was
that that was how class was discussed
where i grew up um you know i think i
think you know so i have two people two
versus that piece there's like this sort
of long version unedited version that i
have on my sub stack and then the
shorter one but in one of those anyway i
write about how i my first job at in
high school i was 15. i was a dishwasher
at this italian restaurant and these
guys that i worked with you know all of
the conversations were about money you
know like i was making minimum wage
washing dishes the guys in the sort of
the cooking station the pizza station
probably weren't making that much more
than me
and so it was like all about you know
buying nice cars and you know some of
these guys played the lottery and it was
just all this discussion of like how to
get more money how broke we were all
this kind of stuff and so that was what
i thought and my family too often
struggled financially
but then i would watch these shows i
would watch um well fresh prince
and uh and another one later on in high
school i watched the oc
and i remember being very confused by
this because these characters like you
know so carlton and will smith in fresh
prince there's like a a big chunk of i
think season three where they're like
obsessing over college applications and
it's not just these shows like if you
watch any sort of teen kind of drama or
whatever like there's always going to be
like an arc about oh getting into
college college applications all this
stuff and but but but carlton was rich
right like aunt viv and uh fulfill like
his family the banks family was rich the
name is banks you know like sort of and
so so so they're rich and and yet it was
critical to carlton to go to college the
question was whether he would go to
princeton or not just like uncle phil
had just like his father and i was
watching this like why does he care if
he wants to call he's already rich he
makes jokes about his inheritance and
they have a butler jeffrey like they
have nice cars like will smith is like
always referencing how he wants to like
drive uncle phil's jag and all this and
i'm like why would you want to go to
college like you're already rich who
cares and uh
exactly and so this was like an inkling
to sort of planted this idea in my mind
that like okay so something's going on
here where even if you have money you
still don't really feel
sort of what um like you're you're
fulfilled or that whatever you're rising
up in society unless you have an
education too
and so you know then later i i wrote in
that piece about um like like uh when i
discovered that it wasn't just money it
wasn't just education uh there seems to
be like the sort of unspoken vocabulary
and taste and habits
also uh that are key ingredients to
class and i talk about mad men and
you know don draper the protagonist of
that show uh you know even though he
sort of looks the part and he's rich and
he works in this you know high
high-flying advertising agency he's
always making these sort of subtle
errors and faux pas that um
you know his co-workers and colleagues
and his boss and his wife who all come
from you know they're actually like sort
of this waspy you know uh wealthy
wealthy members of like new york society
or whatever and they can sort of spot
that don is maybe not who he says he is
or something's off about him
and um
and so that that too sort of helped me
to understand okay so there's something
else going on here and then later i
would read books about class and then by
the time i got to yale it was just like
uh pervasive i realizing uh okay so you
know you can have money you can have the
education but then there's this language
that you have to decode as well if you
really want to be accepted and and
people can sort of spot this um if
they're sort of ensconced in that world
if they're immersed in it and so yeah
that was sort of the purpose of that
that new york times piece
yeah so then this all snowballed into
something that you're super well known
for is this concept of luxury beliefs
and you define it as ideas and opinions
that confer status
on the rich at very little cost while
taking a toll on the lower class and it
kind of speaks to we feel pressured to
within the upper class feeling pressure
to build and maintain social status and
fear losing it so how what was the
initial point where you're like this is
what it is because you know you're
talking these hints of it and then when
did you exactly just declare like this
is a a very
niche concept within
this upper class called luxury beliefs
yeah yeah it's funny so so the idea was
sort of uh
you know sort of swirling in the back of
my mind
you know all throughout my experiences
at yale as an undergrad you know i got
there i was like 24 years old when i
started um so i was a little bit older
and you know i i guess just maybe i had
a little bit more of a distance
perspective i wasn't caught up in like
the whole trying to like chase a finance
or consulting job and going to
internships and everything like i had
already pretty much set my mind to um
applying for a phd program in psychology
so i knew kind of what i wanted to do
and i was always interested in human
behavior
while i was there i would read um
you know of course i'd read like these
modern uh social psychology studies and
evolutionary psychology studies about
how you know status is a fundamental
motive of human beings and you know how
we're constantly seeking esteem and
recognition in the eyes of others and of
course like you know i made the obvious
connection to social media but it's it's
sort of always been present in one form
or another i would read um
like old school sociology thorsten
vablin uh pierre bourdue these kind of
uh classic um
uh social critics and observers who you
know they they would say you know in the
early 20th century for example people
would demonstrate their class with their
material goods
with um you know jewelry or delicate and
restrictive clothing how they present
themselves in public uh a hundred years
ago if you walked around manhattan uh
you would instantly be able to tell just
through visual appearance alone through
material goods who was rich and who was
poor just by how they were dressed
whereas today that may not necessarily
be true
and so i uh my claim is that people have
sort of the upper class specifically
have detached status from luxury goods
and reattaches to luxury beliefs
which are sort of these sophisticated
novel
uh counter-intuitive ideas you know
maybe pseudosophisticated is a better
term that that um essentially go against
whatever the sort of typical
conventional opinion is in society so if
a typical sort of working class or
middle class person believes x then a a
sort of simple way to distinguish
yourself is to say why
uh you know it's something different and
then the way you communicate that
counter-intuitive
luxury belief
is also sort of indicative of your class
you can't just say the belief you have
to express it in in the right way and
the way that you learn how to do that is
through um you know going to an
expensive university uh sort of reading
the right magazines consuming the right
podcasts immersing yourself in the world
of of of luxury belief
and and so this is sort of today how how
status is often demonstrated um is
through luxury beliefs the term itself i
mean i came up with this term and it's
so funny like academics and thinkers
everyone like you know they spend you
know a lot of time trying to come up
with something and the things that they
really want to catch on often don't and
then the thing you just never can
predict other things they just take off
without you even planning on it yeah i
was standing in line at a coffee shop uh
and i you know this idea like i said
percolating in my mind for a while and i
just like wrote this thread about luxury
beliefs and the term just jumped in my
mind while i'm standing in line like oh
luxury beliefs yeah luxury goods luxury
beliefs obviously and i wrote like this
sort of seven part thread uh while i'm
waiting in line and this thing sort of
went viral and then i got some attention
and then i started writing offers to
write these articles and so on and um
and so the idea i think everyone sort of
understood it they um knew what it was
it was kind of in the air and then i
just gave it this this label as a way to
sort of help people to make sense of it
going back to the point of how you grew
up you know you got out of a rare
situation that a lot of people in a
broken quote unquote broken family
situation
have a very tough time getting out of
and you have these different pivotal
points there's a conversation around
young men right now that yang and zach
on this podcast like to talk about often
and this is something that you know you
lived deeply and how
this concept right now there's a lot of
comparison of you know the the gender
gap in different situations where yes
men have traditionally you know been
quote-unquote better in situations but
now women are rising up and that you
don't put a lot of blame on those
specific things you talk about more the
relationships and dynamics of families
and how even relationships are a luxury
belief conversation within the upper
class so there's a finding um
from the early 1960s essentially showing
that family formation and stability was
roughly the same across social classes
so in 1960 95 of children were raised by
both of their birth parents regardless
of social class whether you were really
poor or really rich
you know overwhelmingly the odds are
that the people you know you were raised
by both of your birth parents and then
if you fast forward to 2000 by 2005 uh
it had dropped slightly for the upper
class it'd drop it was 95 it had dropped
to 85 percent so a slight dip but still
the vast majority of upper middle class
and upper class people are are
raised in intact families and for the
working class and the poor it had
plummeted from 95 to 30 in 2005. so it's
actually like it's it's rare it's you're
you're an anomaly now if you're working
in class or poor person and you were
raised by both of your birth parents in
a stable intact family um and you know
what i've written about this i've
discussed my own uh personal experiences
so of course like my own uh turbulent
childhood and youth and then my my five
closest friends in high school you know
these five guys none of them were raised
by both of their birth parents you know
i i contrast this with uh this
experience i had in undergrad at yale uh
the professor administered an anonymous
uh survey to the class there were 20
something students in this seminar
she asked us to respond to this question
um were you raised by both of your birth
parents yes or no
and out of 20-something students it was
just me and one other student who said
no you know i could see like oh there's
only two people well i'm one of them and
then there's someone else in this room
who wasn't yeah and i just floored me
like i would like the first time i saw
that it was because remember i talked
about that uh yale students tend to be
rich but i had no idea that you know not
only was their experience with money
different but also family structure was
like night and day from what i had
experienced growing up so my five
closest friends in in high school you
know one of them was raised by his
grandmother another one raised by a
single mom another raised by single dad
the other one kind of bounced around
different homes and it was just um
that was the sort of typical experience
um
and so so okay so family formation is
important and the reason for this is
because
if you look at
the contributors to sort of risky and
harmful behavior which is
disproportionately committed by men
especially young men there are social
scientists who describe this as um young
male syndrome uh you know who in society
is most likely to commit crimes
especially violent crimes get involved
in drugs and car accidents and
homicide and everything it's it's uh you
know it peaks around age 19 for young
men
um
but what are the contributors of this a
lot of people will point to
socioeconomic status but if you look at
the research um developmental of an
evolutionary psychologist make a
distinction between childhood uh
harshness and childhood instability uh
harshness is essentially poverty or low
socioeconomic status and instability is
um you know it includes number of
relocations in childhood whether you're
raised by both of your birth parents
whether the father was present in the
home whether you lived in foster care
like basically just how disorderly was
your life as a kid
childhood instability is like like far
and away a
much stronger predictor of a child's um
uh outcomes as an adult uh it's
significantly associated with your
likelihood of committing crimes of teen
pregnancy of drug addiction
um it's also a strong predictor of what
psychologists call the dark triad
personality traits uh which are
narcissism psychopathy and
machiavellianism which are associated
with like cynicism hostility
disregard for other people
and in contrast childhood socioeconomic
status is unrelated to
harmful or risky behaviors in adulthood
or uh the dark triad traits so often the
sort of link that we make between
poverty and and all of these negative
outcomes it's actually instability
that's that's what's accounting for
because when researchers look at for
example rich families that are unstable
the number one predictor is childhood
instability because even in rich
families there are sort of these cases
where you know there's divorce and
alcoholism and addiction and rich
families too just not to the same degree
but kids who experience those situations
are also more likely to um sort of
commit
harmful and risky behaviors themselves
so
um and of course like most of this is
isolated among young men
they sort of commit more externalizing
behaviors inflicting pain on the world
and this is why we notice it more and
girls experience a lot of
uh uh detrimental effects too but uh
they they tend to express it in what
psychologists call like internalizing
behavior sort of turning it around on
themselves and and becoming maybe
depressed or anxious or something like
that whereas boys sort of turn it
outward so um and so yeah this is this
is sort of why i think that uh family
and childhood instability is often
overlooked in discussions of like what's
going on with young men why are they
dropping out of college why are they
dropping out of the workforce and so on
so in one of your articles too you spoke
to one of your classmates who she grew
up with monogamous parents and you know
a two-parent household but she seemed to
almost romanticize polygamy even though
did you mention in the article that she
later went on into a monogamous
relationship was that the situation
uh so she was a former classmate of mine
at yale
uh yeah now she works for a tech company
doing very well
she's applying for law schools last
night but but anyway so so she um
yeah she was basically saying that like
monogamy is outdated marriage is this
sort of
what like we need to evolve beyond this
patriarchal institution and so on but
then i asked her well first i asked her
like how she was was raised and
unsurprisingly she was raised by her mom
and her dad and a sort of uh quiet
suburb with you know whatever like
intact family and then i asked her what
she planned to do herself and she said
that she
yeah will eventually probably settle
down and you know get married and have
kids and kind of do the same thing that
her parents did
and so there was this disconnect between
this idea that she was promoting and
espousing belief in
and what she planned to do for her own
life and i and i i pointed this out you
know i did say like well then why are
you saying monogamy's outdated if you're
gonna
you know engage in it yourself yeah and
partake it and she said um
you know yeah i'm just saying like like
for me like that's i guess that's what i
want but it doesn't have to be for
everyone like why do we have to impose
this outdated thing on everyone you know
if they don't want it or if they
whatever and and so there was uh yeah to
me there was like this element of
duplicity between what she planned to do
and and and what clearly works i mean
it's not a coincidence that the vast
majority of students at these top
universities are raised in stable intact
families uh but then if you ask them you
know the the the sort of
fashionable belief is that all families
are the same or you shouldn't judge or
you know any families just as good as
any other
and that kind of thing and and so this
this is a luxury belief because you know
the people who wield the most sort of
social and political and economic
influence in society
are overlooking like basically like one
of the most important contributors to um
social mobility to
sort of stability
for you know mitigating all kinds of
harmful harmful effects for for young
children
you've also spoken to it was more so
referencing an article article that
spoke about how within the upper class
there hasn't been too much variation in
this over the past few decades while um
within like the middle and lower class
there has in terms of more like divorce
higher divorce rates uh people growing
up not within two parent homes so why is
that sticking amongst certain classes
but why is it not sticking in the upper
class
uh that's that sort of non-permissive
non-judgmental attitude has led to to
this kind of situation where the upper
classes are still following these sort
of old school codes of family formation
because that's what they know and that's
what they actually you know if you ask
them like what's the best situation for
for their kids they'll say like oh i
think it should be raised by two parents
and this is part of the reason why uh
single parenthood is so low
fatherlessness rates are very low among
the upper class among the educated class
um
and so they're aware of this but they
won't necessarily espouse this or or
promote this this this view so yeah
basically they're they're kind of
cultural factors at play here for why
um less educated and lower income people
are having kids out of wedlock so of
course men are typical traditionally
like initiate relationships in terms of
setting the tone they're the ones asking
out on dates traditionally et cetera so
you wrote a substance article called no
one expects young men to do anything and
they are responding by doing nothing and
you also make the argument that
young men who grew up in a similar
situation to you growing up or just like
within the realm how we should actually
expect more of them what kind of
messaging can get through to young men
today that are in these hardships and
you know helping them move forward yeah
yeah i mean that is a big part of it too
i mean a big
part of what's going on with family
instability is um fatherlessness so
you know there's there's a great book i
i reference it in that sub stack piece
called promises to keep
by um
well i think the first author is uh
maria kefalis he's like a princeton
sociologist was the the lead author on
that
and they basically say that like a huge
reason for instability is young men in
these poor neighborhoods
are like not uh not very responsible
they interviewed these women
and they'll talk about how these guys
will you know like if they do hold a job
it's only for a few months and then
they'll use the money to buy
you know things that aren't aren't
useful for the kids or for the family
and they're sort of self-centered and
preoccupied with their own needs and not
necessarily of those of their family and
so on
but you know broadly speaking you know
just general like guys in general like
feel i think aimless and adrift and
this is i mean i referenced the young
male syndrome earlier like guys are the
ones who sort of need the most i think
external pressure and guidance in order
to uh you know i mean at the very least
not commit any harm but you know
ideally to sort of
flourish and do well in their lives
and you know especially because like
women are kind of known to be more
self-starters you see that within like
the college application process young
men are typically the worst with sending
in their transcripts and everything like
that like they need what you're saying a
pressure on them
yeah yeah that's right that sort of
orderliness that kind of um
yeah like like procrastination i mean
like everyone procrastinates assembly
but i mean i think like it's most
pronounced among among young guys and so
as far as messaging i mean it's a tough
question like for me obviously we're
working the military and like the
military is like basically the most
like that's the strongest kind of
situation you can be in in terms of
external pressure
and even then there were periods where
you know i i could have made uh some
serious mistakes maybe just got lucky
yeah
and and so so like i mean obviously we
can't have that environment for everyone
but i think like having a little bit of
that would be good
um
you know there have been some different
ideas tossed around i'm not sure how
much stock to put into any of them and
something that i've been thinking about
more about like maybe having more male
teachers or getting more young men
involved in sports
or um you know having like like
neighborhood role models this kind of
thing you know guys who who uh older
older male mentors to at least set a
good example and i think those are all
good ideas um and they certainly
couldn't hurt um but this is uh this is
still something that i've been thinking
about i mean it's it's it's a problem
that that i think we're just now even
even um acknowledging publicly you know
there was that big wall street journal
article i think that came out last year
and that i was surprised to see that
like finally you know like a mainstream
media legacy media outlet is openly
discussing that like yeah uh i think
within the next
five years or something
uh for every uh what is it every two men
that graduate college is going to be
three or or might have been like two to
one some some insane number like that
yes where
the vast majority of of of graduates
will be will be women
and
you know i'm not saying that every
male should go to college
but that those numbers are indicative of
something that's happening here where
guys uh are just sort of feeling aimless
and and not really feeling like uh they
can contribute a lot of the times i
think the role of teachers today can be
great curators um you know like there's
just so much on the internet for these
kids to consume and they often flock to
the mr beast or like the logan pauls of
the world these like huge youtubers that
again it's just like they're not
you know it's entertaining but they're
not necessarily like
great role models because their
situation is like
super outlier like in terms of their
situation yeah i i agree like yeah
they're they're fun and they're
entertaining and whatever but as far as
like
setting down some guidelines or uh
mentorship or anything like that i mean
i i think this is part of why jordan
peterson hit so big with young men and
but whenever they're i mean not whatever
but often whenever there is someone who
who seems to communicate with young men
and inspire them in some way
uh people get nervous about this for
some reason like almost like people are
they they
they don't trust it you know there's
nothing it's extreme something's extreme
about it that every all the men are
flocking to them yeah
yeah like by default if a lot of young
men find your message captivating then
somehow this is uh this is a threat
and
i mean arguably it's a bigger threat for
young men to not have any uh uh
discipline or guidance or or mentorship
in their lives
and i mean we'll see like when you have
large populations of young men who are
restless and don't feel like they are
contributing and and not they don't have
any purpose in society they don't have a
stake in it or an investment
um that that too can be can be quite uh
quite a
you know uh ominous
[Music]
when it comes to these things like
polarization and
looking at reality as maybe subjective
do you feel like the internet
intensifies and like further disperses
these feelings or do you feel like it's
not much different than what it was even
before the internet yeah it's it's
interesting i mean it's
i've seen like mixed research on this
that some people say that you know like
like
much of the the political extremism is
actually happening offline and like
online communities somehow it actually
has this um
kind of buffering effect
uh i guess just because like whatever
content gets curated it actually tends
not to be that extreme i mean you know
like there was a recent paper out about
like you know there's this belief about
youtube
rabbit holes where like oh you know one
minute you're watching like ben shapiro
and then the next year like in this
super right-wing like you know yeah
toxic algorithm but the research seems
to be going against that and and yeah
like a lot of the people who aren't
super online who are like in their own
communities who
you know whatever like they're they're
just not exposed to that stuff like uh
there's yeah suggest suggestive evidence
that they're the ones who are actually
more extreme in their views i'm not
actually sure what to make of any of
this i mean
i think that
yeah i think that the the internet can
contribute to toxic
polarization and
but i but i i'm i'm skeptical that it's
happening uh uh like around the country
i think most of the internet's
polar polarizing effects are among uh
elites or or just highly educated people
because they're the ones who are the
most online i mean most like working
class or blue collar people can't spend
hours a day on twitter yeah or uh you
know consuming all this content i mean
whatever i guess if you're you know it's
some in case you can listen to podcasts
or something but by and large the people
who are like very online are the highly
educated types and that's where i think
like this sort of online internet
polarization stuff is happening
uh where everyone's just sort of
following the people that they like
there's a great paper from dan williams
uh he's a philosophy
uh uh philosopher here here at the
university of cambridge she wrote this
paper called the marketplace of
rationalizations where he basically says
that and i found this pretty persuasive
where he says that now there's um like
people want to believe certain things
and now there's a market opening up
where people can produce content to feed
people
the rationalizations they need to carry
on believing the thing that they want to
believe yeah there's a limit to the
weirdness of arguments that you can
believe in i mean yeah like
most people they have to have like some
level of plausibility for them to
believe in something
and for someone online to sort of feed
it to them in a way that that that is uh
plausible that sounds reasonable that
they can defend to other people um i
think there's a lot of that going on too
where highly educated people are
listening to arguments and ideas and
beliefs that that are flattering to to
their own views
often from like other educated and
interesting people who know how to
formulate persuasive arguments and so so
that's sort of my view is that generally
speaking outside of you know maybe that
top
quintile of of income and education
the internet's probably not doing that
much but i think for for the very online
educated class it's it's it's probably
doing something do you think
polarization is built into human nature
i mean tribalism is probably built into
human nature polarization is
i mean i i don't know probably not
because so so i mean i think of human
nature as you know what what
what were people like before the
agricultural revolution what were humans
like in the pleistocene 20 000 plus
years ago
uh hunter-gatherer bands
uh subsistence living that kind of thing
and
i don't know if like polarization
probably didn't exist at least the way
that we're thinking of it but but
tribalism certainly did i mean there was
sort of inter-coalitionary warfare where
you know these bans would go to war
against one another for resources
for uh for wives for
uh yeah like yeah all kinds of reasons
and so
that is like a key
aspect of human nature is like the sort
of dividing people into us versus them
yeah and you really trust us but they
over there are potentially a threat and
have to be eradicated there's a great
quote i think
i can't remember might have been
friends boas some some anthropologists
from the 20th century who wrote
something along the lines of like for
the vast majority of of human history
um
like the idea of human ended at the
border of the tribe um and so basically
you have your sort of circle of people
that you trust and then like any sort of
homo sapien you encountered outside of
that was actually like they they used
different words like they wouldn't call
them human the words they had for human
were for the people that that were in
their tribe
and it was okay to like you know what uh
uh eat
uh members of the out group and to treat
them any way you want and so on and so
it's it's a
one of the triumphs i think of sort of
what enlightened the enlightenment and
liberal democracies and so on is like
this this sort of expansion of like
understanding that that you know human
beings are the same everywhere and that
everyone has rights and so on and that
just because someone speaks a different
language or is a member of a different
uh group you know whatever ethnic or or
political or what have you that they're
still like human being but yeah you know
i think
maybe the sort of online polarization
stuff is getting people to to forget
about that yeah something really good
i've heard you uh speak to before on
interviews was you know the concept that
free speech cuts against
the grain of human nature and i think
when people write stuff off as human
nature they're like oh just let it be
that's just how it is when in reality
it's like
human nature is it's of course not
always what's good for the long term for
us and there are ways to go against it
and these things that go against it are
can can be net positives just because
they're not in our nature um so i
thought that was very interesting
because you spoke to like the historical
norm of saying what you wanted could get
you killed even before they were
necessarily laws and everything like
that yeah yeah free speech is not uh you
know it's not um
something that comes natural to people
there have always been these sort of
linguistic taboos uh across uh like
throughout and across cultures and
history and so forth and so it's a new
idea free speech and
so
you know like
it's something that i that's kind of i
mean it's still an experiment in many
ways like whether it'll even work it's
something that i you know believe in but
you know trying to take this sort of
realistic stance that okay is this
something that that that can work does
it um
sort of fit with our psychological or
cognitive architecture and so forth and
i think it can i mean if it sort of
evolves naturally in the way that it did
with western society through the
enlightenment and so forth like we sort
of arrived at freedom of speech and
prize it in that way
um
but you know like i i know people who
grew up in very different cultures and
they do not believe in freedom of speech
and i'm you know they've told me like oh
freedom of speech existed in my country
like like there would be bloodshed like
just no question the sort of whether
it's like a very uh i don't know just
just just because of the the norms were
arose organically in those societies in
order to prevent violence and so if you
introduced it it would cause whereas in
our case i'm not entirely sure like
would it be
i i think that we arrived in an organic
and natural way towards freedom of
speech and so if we suppressed it it
would it would actually erupt in in
conflict so human nature in itself is
not this sort of inflexible
uh you know set in stone kind of thing
like you can use certain aspects of
nature to suppress other aspects of
nature too like social pressure is part
of human nature like like falling prey
to
uh your peers and their opinions of you
and so forth and so if something be like
if a sort of something that's sort of
natural becomes like low status then
people won't do it um even though it's
you know part of part of our nature
right and so so i think things can be
sort of uh like certain aspects of of
our psychology can be sort of shaped in
more productive directions
[Music]
among not only the political discourse
but just general discourse we've seen um
an uptick in just like strength and
independent media in terms of younger
generations most of them all flock to in
individual online creators individual
personalities um but traditionally you
know you're going to the legacy media
that are more collectives of people and
collectives of information something i
found super interesting in
discourse or kind of yeah these
political talking heads and how
if they have if you have these daily
shows
and you're reacting to online discourse
and you're reacting to content and
you're specifically under
an ideology
you
you have to
play into that ideology so an example i
saw that was like very interesting to me
the other week was um so sometimes i'll
watch different daily wire shows and one
was ben shapiro and it was a video of um
it was like a disney exec right and
there's a lot of conversation right now
around the disney conversation and how
they they are like changing their um
approach towards youth media
but the disney exec was talking about
how instead of calling kids like boys
and girls they're going to call all kids
dreamers
which you know it's kind of playing into
a uh awoke narrative a little bit but
it's also like at the end of the day
dreamers is just like a cute term you
can't really like refute that too much
so ben's initial reaction as like
someone who reacts to content on a daily
basis on his daily show was you know
extreme it was extravagant it was like
you know i need to make this
entertaining so let me have this extreme
reaction to this and then like he's a
minute or two in and he's like actually
this is kind of dumb let's move on but
it was just so fascinating for me to see
that initial reaction of like i i have
to react this way because this is like
what i do this is how i uh sustain
myself this is how i get views all this
stuff so it's interesting to see like um
you know independent media often talks
to
uh we are away from the establishment
therefore all the corruption is gone
everything like that but at the end of
the day you still have an algorithm to
attend to your algorithms are your boss
in order for you to make this money and
you have to play into the extremes still
yeah like i i mean i've i remember so
when i i launched this sub stack
and
i was looking at others you know like
because you have to like create this
sort of like welcome page and you know
thanks for signing up and that great
stuff looking at some others there's uh
there's one i mean
there's one by uh matt taibbi i think it
was his
right
where
his welcome so so after you subscribe he
sends you the welcome email and i think
the last line or second to last line it
was something like i work for you now
yes basically like you signed up you're
paying money to read my my thoughts and
responses to whatever the trends are
and so therefore i'm i'm working for you
and i found that interesting because on
the one hand it's true but on the other
like it's it's a very sort of
transparent acknowledgement of like
you know uh of a sort of like a
performance you know like you're a
you're a busker right like you're sort
of people are paying you and you're
doing something like performing in a way
and
so yeah i mean
there's um
i guess there's no escaping that yeah
whether you work for legacy media or you
do your own thing or work for
independent media like you
if you work in the world of ideas
and that's how you
uh sort of make your way make your money
make whatever like that's that you just
have to play that game but there's no
escaping that yeah and i think like yeah
there's an honesty to that i guess like
if you say that like yeah like you're
we are responding to what you want i
guess like where the sort of you know
there's this term that's thrown around a
lot on twitter and stuff like grifter
you know this griffer idea like what
where is the line between
you know just sort of doing your job or
grifting because like you could also say
i mean if the idea of grifter is just
like
you're you're validating your audience's
opinions then like literally everyone
who works in the world of ideas who has
an audience is a grifter but i think
grifter is
i think there's a maybe more subtle
definition which is you
uh are saying things you don't
necessarily believe but you know your
audience does
in order to
gain followers or or subscribers or
money or whatever that if you're willing
to sort of i guess i said this is a sort
of selling app that's the grifter is
like the updated term i guess is just
selling out of like you're doing things
that you don't agree with or believe in
in order to you know raise elevate
yourself in some way
and so yeah but but but at the end yeah
there's there's sort of no escaping of
having an audience and telling what they
want to hear and and and i think like
the best
people in
independent media at least uh are
willing at times to upset their own
audience and those are the people that i
tend to like that i'm actually willing
to sort of like sign up for and to read
or listen to or whatever is like yeah i
know that this was a risk for this
person to write this or to say this on
their podcast or have this guest on who
most of their audience will hate
uh that's something that i that i
respect
a tweet that i found really interesting
of yours a few weeks ago
and i would love for you to elaborate on
is you quote tweeted someone who said
what's a view you have that most people
disagree with
and yours was boomers aren't that bad
and when millennials and gen z ascend to
power things will get worse
well okay so
yeah yeah
it's it's something that i stand by yeah
i i 100 believe this i
i just um
by worse i don't know how much worse and
in what form it'll take
but all of the trends i'm seeing just
don't really bode well for like a stable
cohesive society i mean trust is at an
all-time low i mean i'll give you an
example of this so uh in in 1959
56
of 18 to 24 year olds said that other
people are generally trustworthy so more
than half like a majority of the people
majority of young adults said yeah most
people generally trustworthy uh today
the number is 30 so it's basically been
cut in half over the last what 60-ish
years uh trust among young adults has
has plummeted yes um
the you know sort of views about like
you know whether you trust your
neighbors whether you like you know or
uh you know there's another survey from
pew which is something like uh you know
do you believe that people uh you know
care about others are they just sort of
looking out for their own interests and
you know those
are declining among young people as well
over time interactions with with
neighbors like how often do you greet or
interact with your neighbor i mean in in
the late 90s it was most young people
said yes to this question and today it's
like a
pronounced minority you know just a
small number of people so so generally
like you know all of these things
cooperation trust um willingness to
engage and then of course like the
marriage rates right like marriage rates
are plummeting among young people i
think among young men at least
i can't remember that the age cut offs
but like under 34 or something andrew
yang might have might have written about
this in
one of his one of his essays about how
now more young men live with their
parents than live with a partner yep um
you know and so like is that is that
like the sort of recipe for you know
having like good leaders and good people
in society uh you know people who are
still sort of living off of their
parents rather than than trying to like
become reliable people who others can
can can rely on right like there's
there's a huge difference between
relying on others versus being relied
upon yep and more and more young people
it seems are are more likely to be
relying on others than becoming the kind
of people who can be relied upon and and
then of course like i've brought this up
with people and they oftentimes they
just react with anger how dare you and
then they point to all of these sort of
economic trends or what have you and and
like fine but like it's not as if
you know the trends today are worse than
you know say like like the great
depression or or even the great
recession of 2008 like we've had like
worse economic
uh downturns in society you know
stagflation in the 70s and so on um
but even during those periods right like
the sort of general attitude in the
malaise around young people just just
was not nearly as
as
what exaggerated or pronounced as it is
now so
that was the reason why i said that the
other thing is like i think like the
polarization is going to get worse and
and it's going to look it's going to
take on like strange forms i think
because the boomers
even though like maybe they were i don't
know to some degree they were
politically polarized and
have different ideas about
society and politics and government yeah
regardless of party they still had ideas
in mind about like a life script of like
getting married having kids and so forth
right like every president we've had has
sort of followed that that that path
um
i think now
because of the sort of increased levels
of social permissiveness the lifting of
the cultural guard rails and so on and
people are partitioning into their
respective political camps we're going
to have situations in the future where
like remember like you know millennials
or or gen z
we're like you're going to have one
presidential candidate who is sort of
married and has kids like this
conventional typical family formation
and then you're going to have
like candidates on the other side who
like live in a polycule and have all
kinds of like you know whatever like
interesting experiences with different
partners and so on because because
that's sort of becoming acceptable in
society as a whole and i think like
having that level of polarization where
like now your two candidates are living
like
like they're unrecognizable from one
another in terms of how they live their
lives and their family formations and so
forth i just don't know if that's like a
recipe for uh for a stable society um
having some level of sort of cohesion
and similarity in life scripts and so on
i think like that is is is beneficial
maybe individually it's um
what confining but in terms of the
society it's actually it's actually
often a good thing so so that was why i
wrote that i think a lot of the trends
are looking a little bit grim yeah i
think there's also not necessarily a
north star today in terms of like a few
decades ago the american dream you know
was white picket fence you have a family
all that now
it's so varying especially since even
some younger people think that like
having kids could be unethical when it
comes to climate change stuff like
there's those conversations
too like what you're saying exactly like
how you live your life to down to those
things like uh
everything's like oh if the extreme of
oh if you oppose what i think is moral
then you are bad
inherently well i don't think that like
i mean
in terms of like worse like i i don't
want to say that like there are worse
people i think like there's also avenues
for people to express sides of themself
that that didn't exist in the past for
sure
20 years ago you couldn't see uh members
of congress
you know like like like
behaving like 13 year olds you know on
social media yeah yeah uh that maybe
they would have like if twitter had
existed in 2002 like you know right
after 9 11 if you could see like the
reactions of congress to that event like
i think you know we would be horrified
you know especially if you can get likes
and retweets and clicks and validation
for sharing them
but now it's like it's just weird now
for like if you're a 15 year old kid
and you get on social media and you see
like the leaders of your country
saying things that like you said when
you were in eighth grade uh i think like
that also has like toxic detrimental
effects on society too where like the
people you're supposed to look up to and
aspire to be or respect in some way you
see that like they
like you're seeing like the nastiest
size of their personality and often like
the people in those positions don't
think about this and so so it's not to
say like they're inherently worse but
now we have opportunities to express
those ugly sides of ourselves that that
previous generations didn't have well
yang has talked about this before too of
like you know gen x is kind of the
forgotten generation in conversations we
always skip over them often where it's
like boomers and then like we always go
to millennials and gen z and he talked
about how he he was talking to a friend
and his friend kind of pinpointed that
gen x is going to be essential and the
role of of course boomers are kind of
still at the forefront of government
conversations right now but gen x is
going to play a big role in terms of
yeah social the social media
conversations and everything going on
there because they were a generation
that completely grew up without social
media like millennial generations still
grew up
pretty in depth with the internet even
though social media wasn't too big until
like 2010 2012 era there's a great book
uh it just came out the 90s by chuck
closterman who's uh i think it's closer
man actually he's a um
a gen xer he's more like that like mid
late 70s or something but he in this
book he has this line which is really
good which is um you know like
there's a lot of
like gen x has a lot of faults you know
they were sort of like disengaged
apathetic all this stuff
but they do have sort of one redeeming
quality which is that they're the least
annoying yes the currently existing
generations
uh he talks about how you know they they
sort of come whatever like they
complained less than the generations
that came both before and after them
and uh and it is interesting like part
of the reason why i think they're
overlooked is because like they don't
complain they don't make noise like part
of how you get attention and how you um
sort of uh uh
get the get the policies you wanted
active and so forth is to agitate and to
draw attention to yourselves and to make
life miserable for other people and gen
x just didn't do that like they were
uninterested in and then they still seem
to be sort of uninterested in that and
so it's been interesting to see like
maybe maybe as the the boomers uh sort
of recede from from
leadership roles and gen x
will replace some of them that maybe
they'll they'll help steer steer the
ship in different direction
that would be nice yes like you know i'm
a fan of gen x you know pressure guys
but for real
[Music]
i saw you um shared a study talking
about like we are not built to be happy
evolution doesn't want us to be in
constant bliss some degree of
unsettledness anxiety and ambition might
be baked into the human condition and
again to what we talked about earlier
human nature isn't always something that
we have to stick by blah blah but
i find stuff like this even though it's
saying oh like uh
as humans we are not meant to be happy
and a lot of people might look at that
as a negative i find stuff like this
pretty liberating in the same way i find
like mortality liberating because i
think it like pushes you to against that
pressure to make the most of your days
and
all that
so
just like yeah getting into the
liberation of this and the ability for
people to let go of this feeling of when
they are not happy because i think a lot
of young people today and a lot of young
men like we were speaking of earlier
just put
when they are unhappy that something is
wrong with them and kind of just
clarifying what you believe within human
nature of
how you should kind of approach
unhappiness
it's a good question i mean it's uh
that that that idea
repeatedly comes up in a lot of the
evolutionary psychology research on
happiness is that happiness is not like
it's it
it's not an end in itself uh
evolutionarily speaking it was it's a
motivator it's something to sort of
drive you towards something so like if
you think about the times you feel happy
the feeling of happiness is like an
evolutionary payoff to do something that
in the ancestral environment
uh increased your ability to survive or
attract allies or romantic partners or
obtain resources or status and so on um
and so
and so it wasn't and in itself it was
just a means to to an end it was it was
a sort of a carrot on the end of a stick
and so
to me that was liberating too to
understand that because
you know we always think at least like
people especially people who are who are
young who are ambitious who are striving
for something it's you know you always
think it's like that next thing like if
i could just do this one thing then i'll
be happy just this sort of next
milestone then i'll be set and then you
achieve it and you're happy for like
you know a week and then and then you're
on to the next thing and uh i i can't
remember where i read this but basically
it's um
i wrote this somewhere that that it's
achievements are like a warm bath where
at first you get in there and it feels
great and then pretty soon it feels like
nothing at all
um
and so so to to keep that in mind that
uh the struggle is sort of built in to
the human condition that it'll always be
there with us and that just because you
feel some unhappiness
i mean yeah i think like
part of just getting older too is just
realizing that whatever you're feeling
unhappy or or down or in some way like
it passes like a lot of this stuff is
just sort of momentary
experiences on your emotional ticker
and it'll sort of pass by and you'll
feel good again or you'll feel back to
your sort of baseline again
um
a lot of unhappiness seems to have been
kind of like medicalized or like people
immediately jump to like these kind of
like
psychiatric diagnoses or something oh
yes
i mean this is not to downplay it or say
that like this doesn't exist or people
don't experience depression and anxiety
and so forth like i get all of that but
you know there's uh there's
interesting research showing that um
you know one big predictor of happiness
is sort of living an ethical life
and doing like the right thing and
there's there's a psychiatrist theodore
dalrymple who's writing i really like
where he says that like we sort of
separated
um
behavior from feeling we're like oh if
you feel bad it's a sort of uh it's a
brain chemistry problem it's uh it's a
medical problem
and it's
has nothing to do with how you're
behaving in your day-to-day life but
often you know what makes you feel good
uh are doing things that that are sort
of have positive effects for yourself
for your loved ones for your social
circle for your community
and yeah it's surprising i think people
are often yeah
they don't understand that like if you
feel down doing something nice for
someone else is often uh uh a
shrewd way to feel better yourself um
but often especially like i think yeah
younger people and and
people in in our culture in general are
just sort of preoccupied and
self-centered and don't realize that you
know sort of being so caught up in your
own head and
in your own thoughts like that is that
is often a recipe for unhappiness and
and and a solution oftentimes is to just
step outside of yourself and wonder like
what can i do for other people and that
can be a cure often the happiest people
you'll ever meet almost never think
about themselves i agree wow word what a
great place to end thank you so much rob
for being here and where can people find
you as well as more of your work online
so they can definitely access that in
the future well my sub stack rob k
henderson so rob the letter k
henderson.substance.com and you can
follow me on twitter at rob k henderson
yeah i just became a subscriber on
substance so yeah i definitely recommend
that to everyone thank you for being
here rob
thanks jules
[Music]
you